ah che bella sensazione che stiamo per
provare ve lo giuro belle agenti ragazzi
e benvenuti questo video sono favi g.col
cerotto è una skin queste non sono così
normalmente vi spiego allora sono erano
un po io volevo fare sto video però velo
articolo un attimo nel corso degli anni
rispetto a tutti questi miliardi di
iscritti ho fatto dei video che sono
diventati più popolari del canale non ne
abbiamo cinque che sono sopra i 10
milioni di views che sono le due parole
di punt hellas momenti epici di video
che in 7 cross basso rango e mail e aids
in italia quando vado a vedere quante
luciano fatto certi miei video di kobo
tipo il mio draw my life
oppure la challenge delle squeak però
bene anzi sono contentissimo se
clicchiamo questo magico tasto e
facciamo ordine ad almeno recente dei
miei video
andiamo su quella bellissima categoria
che sono i primi video di un canale in
questo caso del mio senza dare troppo
nell'occhio delle copertine grazie a dio
c'è un video in particolare che merita
la vita che è stato il momenti epici dei
videogames che il mio primo speciale su
youtube speciali sono quando raggiungi
un traguardo di iscritti ai tempi aver
raggiunto 10.000 iscritti che hanno
trovato gigantesco allora avevo fatto
sto speciale che racchiudeva i momenti
più fighi di tutte le mie giocate ai
tempi tolto iniziato a fare video a
gennaio del 2013 questo è uscito a marzo
quindi erano solo due mesi più o meno di
raccolta di vini neanche tanto senza
andare troppo a vedere nei commenti
della gente che scrive ranchero meglio
nel prima perché fa figo scriverlo
sempre l'impavido nei commenti che eri
il meglio prima
e proprio con la frase classica che è
una stronzata per una disciplina figo
yeah che l'unica roba che è cambiata a
parte i miei capelli sono il microfono
che si sente meglio è un rom pelo di
meno e dico meno parlarci interessava la
parola cacao perché la dico di continua
in questi video ci sono altri siti un po
meno per minorenni dove ne vedete un
sacco a proposito della parola cup in
questi video siccome è pieno di parole
dica ora vi parli tutti in montaggio
perché sono il video non è più family
friendly ringraziando la nuova politica
di youtube che non puoi dire la parola
che dobbiamo fare la reaction questa
cosa perché merita la vita non vi
spaventate se c'è un bip al secondo
ai tempi ero così ero meglio perché
dicevo solo caso avevo solo quello in
vocabolari ottimo 3 1 salve no un altro
ascensore perfetto così il cap counter
siamo a 1 per adesso sarà the crush saga
che ricordi pronto pizza si una quattro
formaggi è una margherita si ok perfetto
la seconda più richiesta invece è stato
fa vj cioè molti di voi mi hanno chiesto
zio guerra cura dei feriti
qualcosa o creatore stesso scrive la
sera fichissimo scrive la sala suo gioco
dove scrivi su un taccuino il nome di
una cosa che volevi si materializzasse
tipo frigorifero e quello che lo metteva
è un sito fa vigili stesso però ragazze
io scrivo dei nomi veri lui non può
materializzare questo penombra e
bellissimo 8 fatto male il personaggio
di sto gioco
e sapete cosa è fatta ancora più male
del personaggio il mio outfit titolo che
è veramente ragazzi le lance in un'ora
in piaciuto credibile ritorno more che
non mi è piaciuto ma penso che sia
bambino che corre nudo
raga mi è venuta un'idea prova godere di
una frase sono tipo tre parole di tre
parole c'erano quattro parolacce però
era meglio prima importante quello qua
ci vuole la musichetta adatta
[Musica]
questa è la bellissima questa lo ammetto
era veramente stavo scherzando per
cassetti fantastico tipo come se fosse
casa mia o di witch 9 la nutella per
verificarlo era partita tutto il da
questa frase da questa precisa frase era
partito il trend della nutella che mi ha
accompagnato per non so quanti anni
forse ancora adesso ancora con cui porta
delle stelle da quella da quella scena
li nei libri di storia era piace eccome
no no no no parola con questo gioco
quello dove riportare la gara capitolo
ma che è successo era un video natalizio
non so se si vede c'è avevo quel capo
detto vabbè è nata le faccio vedere che
faccio cose che segue i trend dei
natalizi avevo messo il cappello
proprio questo video si che natalizio ce
lo percepiscono lo spirito del natale
pure il mostro ce l'aveva il cappello
wow che tempi no no no no non ci credo
dove nobel due quarti sono scene brutta
mamma mia che kringe orribile che brutte
robe vedo mamma mia ragazzi quarto d'ora
ancora stovini cinque minuti basta vi
prego a 2 milioni e mezzo di views ma
dio mio
dove sono i commenti negativi voglio
vedere quelli negativi
voglio che i test dove sono gli hater
tra l'altro la avevi il microfono
altissimo lo zio non avevo proprio un
microfono c'era orribile che sta usando
le cuffie sono le stesse se guardate non
è proprio sulle stesse che adesso era
questo
questo qua ma questo non è un microfono
questo è queste satana c'è qua mi senti
non so sentì la voce del demonio è
orribile sta roba ringraziando iddio ci
ha avuto un miglioramento investito nel
nell'attrezzatura la videocamera ho
cambiato solo adesso perché fino a ieri
però in questo periodo il mio cellulare
no no no no no sentivamo urlare queste
esatte cosa vi sta sentendo dalla mia
camera senza capire che cosa io stessi
facendo mappa per farvi cei buy back
door riesce a raggiungere il traguardo
me lo chiedi anche ma scherzi c'è il
traguardo traguardo il mio secondo nome
ok bene facciamo al mio terzo i bei
tempi di happy with proprio sono i
nostri quattro digeriti stamattina ok
sta arrivando da qualche parte diritti
umani su due raso l'estero non
certamente da conservare in de franco e
per io perché ce l'avete sentito questa
dall'anteprima visto bene ce la facciamo
da me c'è un bello fu hanno usato
qualcosa ha pensato non è veramente lui
che la lascia la me magari poi la festa
oa nodo qualche frase egeria ok allora
questa festa la bella ragazzi e non so
quanto siamo di contatore perché non c'è
noi ditero dopo questo video però prova
a sparare a quanto siamo di di counter
saremo tipo a 12 ed è un solo video uno
a mio zio del film va bene è stato un
bel momento questo video non sarà mai
monetizzato nella vita perché dio mio
però guardiamoci il 2 il 2 era ancora
più interessante perché con il 2
eravamo arrivati a quanti iscritti di fo
20.000 25.000 iscritti quail vogliamo
vecchio fa vj ma vengo a casa vostra vi
prendo a sberle con la carne surgelata
meno male che qualcuno che ragiona non
capisco perché la gente voglio ancora
fare questo famiglie con i noodles i
noodles è ancora pieno di robe di
degrado
non oso pensare però c'è anche il cat
mario avevo introdotto questa perla del
mio del mio del mio canale lavo
introdotta in questo momento wow pre
vorrei
utilizzare una roba noi andiamo su
momenti epici dei video che la mia tutta
la mia playlist quello che ha fatto più
views i nas questi avevano due milioni e
mezzo della tantissimo ea questo ragazzo
fra quanti 12 milioni e mezzo
questo video ha fatto 12 milioni mi
milioni di views come come comunque
ragazzi rispetto a quanto abbiamo visto
è stato proprio un bel tuffo nel passato
cioè rispetto anche a inter siamo alcune
scene erano carina effettivamente non
era tutto uno schifo ci stavano più
rotanti di quelle cose veramente troppo
kringe cioè ricordarlo non non riuscì io
non riesco riguardo al mio video vecchio
cioè non riesco a guardare dei miei
video vecchia a parte questo che era il
momenti epici proprio in generale della
scrive self incassi sono a caso non
riuscire a guardarlo però sono tempi si
cresce si cambia
grazie a dio vi dico la verità un po mi
manca un po mi manca quel periodo e cioè
nel senso era un po schifo perché andavo
a scuola facevo i video quindi non
vivevo più però allo stesso tempo c'è un
po di nostalgia celo celo comunque
perché dio mio bello era un bel periodo
anche adesso vivo un bel periodo tra
cinque anni
ulteriori di rho cavolo che bel periodo
che erano cinque anni fa quindi anche
oggi un bel periodo quindi vivete vi
posso presente perché un giorno sarà il
vostro passato va bene ragazzi questo
ero io ero spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero vi siano piaciuti anche i video
vecchi come al solito seguito è piaciuta
c'è un momento mi piace anche la pagina
di vista granché come la videonotizia
resi schiavi
noi ci vediamo al prossimo
[Musica]